joining me now somebody who has known
mark zuckerberg for years one of the
savviest observers of big tech
kara swisher host of the sway podcast
and a contributing opinion writer for
the new york times
cara such a pleasure to have you on the
show pleasure to be here
thank you for having me on your
delightful peacock show
it's lovely thank you lovely uh
here's a quick question for you opening
question for you who has more influence
over this
election in your opinion rupert murdoch
or mark zuckerberg
mark zuckerberg no question hands down i
mean rupert murdoch is an irritating
uh toxic uh waste dump of
of all kinds of media properties but it
has a much smaller reach than facebook
does
and so facebook really does set the tone
for everything and allows people to run
rampant including
fox news on its platform
yes good point good point facebook
actually empowers fox
news even further i mean here's what's
so amazing the precursor of facebook
was a website built in zuckerberg's
college dorm room which he
used to score the looks of women how do
we get to a point today where facebook
now is not just this massive platform
they even admitted that they helped
contribute to genocide in myanmar
you have this situation where u.s
senators are accusing them as they did
today
of being the single biggest threat to
free speech in america how do you go
from
that to that i just sometimes find it
hard to get my head around that
the sort of hot or not app that he was
doing is different from what facebook
was but it was that was another thing he
made um so there were separate things
but
you know it just was a great idea this
idea and it wasn't a fresh idea there
were all kinds of
people doing this and there were many
competing uh companies at this myspace
and a bunch of others
so it was an idea that we can all meet
online not unlike america online a long
time ago
and so uh it was it was it was something
that he did and he's an excellent
he's excellent at execution he's
excellent at building companies he hired
the right people
and they managed to really figure out a
business plan unfortunately the business
plan
suggests that we need constant uh use of
this product and
people who are enraged are better than
than than other people and so to
push engagement he allowed this platform
to just thrive without very
very few guard rails um and quite a lot
of free speech
too much of it uh misinformation and
then disinformation which are two
separate things
you know the guy you've interviewed and
we played a clip of you speaking to him
earlier about holocaust denial
on issues like the fake news stuff and
the russian interference
and holocaust denial and enraging people
on the right how much of that
is he just went along with it he was
ignorant how much of it was
he knew but he didn't really care uh
it's hard to say
you know mark is not a malevolent person
by nature he is not i mean
it was you can hear him talking and
trying to get to the right answer
i think the issue is that this platform
is just too big and without any rules
and he would like you to have it both
ways which is
to take this idea of free speech and
take it to an extreme that is that
doesn't make any sense there's no
uh there's no way that you could have
disinformation misinformation
hate speech all sit together with what
most people consider free speech
uh on the same platform without a lot of
problems and
in that case and also within so many
countries and across the world and
billions of people
and so one of the things i always think
about is jiren lanier who
talked about this he was talking about
people getting off of facebook many
years ago
and such and social networks um was that
this is the biggest
experiment in human communications and
it's failing badly
um especially because there's no guard
rails and so
that's what these hearings are supposed
to get at this hearing today was an
embarrassment it was ridiculous
um you know uh dipped down the alley of
conservatives thinking there's bias
which is just it's just not true there's
it's evidence-free they just say it over
and over again and hope that people will
believe it which many people do but it's
disinformation
for sure yeah i want to come back to the
bias point in a moment you mentioned
you know it got too big for him do you
think the pretty critical tone taken by
senators today from both parties suggest
that at some point soon
there is going to be an attempt maybe a
bipartisan attempt to break up facebook
and would that be a good thing in your
view
well i think it's part of the bigger uh
issue of all of them what
what what is the power of all these tech
companies who have very little
regulation
uh surrounding them and the regulation
that exists is actually very good for
them you know it's very it's very
helpful
legislation like section 230 of the
communications decency act which
grants them broad immunity which at one
point was a good idea
now it has to be thought about again it
doesn't mean it has to be eliminated by
the way and president trump has tried to
do that whenever he has a peek with
twitter he
he issues an executive order that makes
no sense um
the issue i have with a lot of this is
that you know like any big industry
whether it's finance or cars or
airplanes
they're in need of regulation right and
and we have our legislators who are
elected officials
uh that are supposed to do that um and
so what was
what's interesting is there's been no
regulation for what is the most
important
industry right now in the world the
richest people and
the richest companies the most valued
companies and so
i think there is a time to get together
in a bipartisan way and talk about
things like 230 talk about
speech talk about bigness and i think
it's really all about
what louis brandeis called the curse of
bis bigness which was way back when when
they were passing the sherman antitrust
act
and and before before that and so
they've done this before our country
has done this before and so the issue i
have is that we we aren't looking
in a substantive bipartisan and cogent
way we have
uh people like ted cruz making things up
um and not it's not helpful
to take shots at these companies in ways
that are unhelpful and untrue
we have to have a group of people that
sits down and takes it apart very
carefully
and thinks about remedies that are very
wide-ranging not just breaking up but
regulation
such as a private national privacy bill
fines such as what the fbc can levy et
cetera et cetera et cetera
so cruz and trump and others have
obviously pushed this
kind of myth that facebook is biased
against conservatives
even though facebook reports on its top
10 performing link posts yes
uh every day it puts out the list of
them and those that list clearly shows
uh kind of a bias towards conservative
media topics and outlets
um margaret sullivan and margaret
sullivan wrote in the washington post
this week
that the top performing facebook posts
day after day are dominated by pro
trump voices or sites like fox news
breitbart franklin graham and ben
shapiro
when facebook adjusts its practices or
tweaks its algorithm
those changes make a huge difference
often these days it's left-leaning news
sites
that take the hit uh cora zuckerberg
says he's a liberal he donates to
liberal causes again
does he recognize that his site is
promoting conservative misinformation on
a daily basis or is he turning a blind
oh he's aware of it i wouldn't say he's
a liberal like silicon valley it's such
a myth that silicon valley people are
liberal
they may vote um okay all right they're
they i call them libertarian light
is what i tend to look at like no harm
no foul for everything
um but you know i say light because i
don't think any of them understand it
really what
real libertarianism is um but you know
this idea of bias look at that list
that didn't look like a list of you know
fair you know fair and balanced by any
stretch of the imagination
and it's not a myth it's a lie it's an
actual lie and so
it was incredible to me is when these
groups
try to say they are being censored i
look at lists like this and i
see them talking all the time right i
shouldn't you know i think alex jones
was on
spotify the other day on joe rogan's
show i think that ted cruz
yammered on on twitter today they never
shut up
really that's the issue and i think the
issue um what was
really interesting about a lot of the
stuff today is it was essentially
people who break rules complaining that
they're getting in trouble for breaking
rules
right like president trump has been
censored
president trump has broken rules
hundreds of times and they only recently
started to
to let him you know adhere to the rules
it's it's the strangest thing that you
just you want to complain about being
able to break the rules
that you say are being broken against
you and so if you break the rules more
yes you get dinged more and you know if
you jaywalk all the time you get tickets
i don't know what to say when they
make these specious arguments and there
are big issues around free speech which
is that one person
does control a major platform and he
cannot be fired
that is a big issue we all need to talk
about together instead of getting on
this like
agreed you know this weird alley way of
of
right and left it's not that's not what
it's about it's about power
this week on your podcast sway you spoke
to hillary clinton and you asked her why
attacks on joe biden and hunter biden
aren't working for trump this time
around but they seem to resonate in 2016
when it came to her
here's what she said you know there were
academic studies done afterwards lots of
them
about why people ended up not voting for
me
and it was shocking what they believed i
mean the disinformation
was incredibly
pervasive and one very influential
piece of totally false news was pope
francis had endorsed
trump and where did they get that they
got that delivered in their facebook
feeds
and one was that i was dying i was
constantly dying
and still not dead yeah i am still so
far as i know
walking and talking and breathing this
time around do you think the facebooks
and twitters of this world
are over compensating or over correcting
recently we saw
them blocking or slowing down the spread
of a dodgy new york post piece about
hunter biden do you think that backfired
on them
you know i think they're trying to
figure it out and what happened is they
haven't done it forever it's sort of
like
uh feeding your toddler sugar for years
and then suddenly withdrawing it i mean
i don't know what else i mean i have
kids i don't know if you have kids but
you have to like this is they should
have been doing this from the beginning
they should have actually been
enforcing their rules and they didn't
and i think so that people at first are
shocked that there's rules
uh which they should be because they've
never been been
subject to them before and then secondly
they're not very
they pretend they're not media companies
when in fact they are and so they make
bad calls they make very bad calls
and so they've trained people to think
of them as the public square when in
fact they are not the public square they
are not
you know ted cruz i think today who was
just the worst because he's
much smarter than the rest of them now
who who elected you
and who made you boss i was like nobody
these are
these are you were elected but they
weren't elected and secondly
who made them boss they invented it and
they made themselves boss of the company
i don't know what
these are private companies they have
public shareholders but they are private
companies owned by people and they can
do
whatever they want the thing is they're
not very good at it and they have to
figure it out on the fly especially in
this highly partisan
um atmosphere and especially when um
especially president trump is trolling
them almost continually just
daring them to do something and he's
been trained to do that you know what
honestly
he should do it that's that's what he
should do i don't even blame him for
doing it at this point
[Music]
so you mentioned the trump and the
trolling he's of course best known for
his twitter account not for his facebook
page
you wrote in the new york times that
twitter must cleanse itself
from the trump stain how is that going
to be possible especially since this is
a platform
that has refused to ban him out right
you mentioned a moment ago it came very
late to even correcting his
tweets on coronavirus i don't believe
they should ban him unless he truly
breaks
the laws that the rules that get people
banned right like what happened to alec
jones and others
um i do think there is some news um
value from having him on that platform i
think if he suggests violence or things
like that
that was many that was a couple years
ago when i was saying that i was saying
that look
he doesn't get to he gets to break the
rules all the time
and you should do something about that
which they have done
twitter doesn't actually take them down
actually with president trump
they either put something above a tweet
something like covet can be cured by a
hydroxychloroquine something
inaccurate and dangerous they cover it
up and say here's the actual information
or
or they put right below it this tweet is
not true
such and such and that to me is not
that's not censorship it's just saying
hey really you shouldn't be injecting
yourself with bleach or whatever it is
he happens to say that day
you know that's what they're doing
that's called editorial control over
their platform
facebook actually takes things down
which is interesting they have
another rule so every different site has
a different rule of what they're going
to do reddit has a different one
um the only one that doesn't have it is
something like snapchat which
you know doesn't have this problem
because it doesn't you know it doesn't
traffic in this kind of
um wide broadcasting of information
cara swisher we're going to have to
leave it there thank you so much for
your time and your insights